I'm going to share with you seven ways
to how you can make a million p in
property or in business now this is the
cool thing about these seven ways I'm
going to share you about how to make a
million pounds all seven of these ways
to make a million pound I have actually
done not only have I done all seven of
them but I've also made a million pounds
using each strategy yes I'm a
multi-millionaire so maybe you could
just take one if I can do all seven
maybe you just take one make1 million
cool then invest that put that to work
and and um massively increase the
quality of your life the first way is
company valuations let me give you an
example right and I've done this many
times let's say you want to be a
millionaire what is a millionaire well a
millionaire is someone that has a
million pounds netw worth so that means
that if you add what they own and then
you minus what they owe whatever's left
if there's a million pounds there then
your net is a million pounds let's take
a company like deal sourcing okay which
was my first big business deal sourcing
is where you find deals property
Investments you package them and you
sell them to investors now on average if
you're charging £3,000 as a fee and
you're getting three grand well if you
want to make a million pound from deal
sourcing the average person that's not
smart to business will we thinking well
a million P divided by 3,000 means I
need to sell 333 deals to make a million
p and not only that but I got to keep
all the profit which is not possible
because you've got expenses and you've
got running costs 333 deals to to sell
that many deals and keep all the money
is not easy to to become a millionaire
so what's the fast way company valuation
way well I'll tell you the fast way
would be if you would to say actually
you know what I'm going to do I'm not
going to sell 333 deals to become a
millionaire and save all no no I'm going
to sell two deals a week I'm going to go
real hardcore and sell just two deals a
week now if you if I'm if I'm selling
two deals a week and I'm making £6,000 a
week that is per year 6,000 a week there
52 weeks in the year that's 312 so
suddenly see it's it's more realistic
312 Grand in a year so how do you become
a millionaire from that if you've got a
business that's doing 312 Grand a year
well within deal selling you only need
two or three people good people this is
what I did with deal selling if you've
got a deal selling company that's
selling two deals a week if you can hire
a managing director and an assistant and
a part-time bookkeeper the business is
pretty much running itself let's say
you're paying 100 Grand in wages and
you've got two people one's on 60 Grand
One's On 30 grand and you got a parttime
bookkeeper that means now you've got two
about 200 Grand a year profit and you're
just overseeing the business you're not
the person that's doing everything in
the business now you've got a salable
business you've got your invest list
you've got your company you tried and T
tried and tested you've got your staff
you've got your operations manual you
got your organizational structure now if
You' got 200 Grand a year profit coming
in times that by 10 that's 2 million
well a 10x multiplier for a business
valuation is pretty standard so you
could very easily set up a business like
deal sourcing for example structure it
systemize it employ a few members of
staff and get a million pound valuation
on the company and if you own a company
that's worth a million pound if it's a
million pound company then guess what
that means you are a millionaire that's
one way of how you can become a
millionaire through companies and
Company valuations second one is rent to
rent now you might think when you think
of rent to rent oh you know I haven't
got much money and I've only got a few
grand and I'm struggling haven't got
enough money to buy property so I'll do
rent to rent instead do you know does
rent to rent you know most hotels do
rent to rent Premier in don't own most
of their hotels 95% of them are rent to
rents I took a rent to rent on maybe 3
months ago a hotel not even a big hotel
34 rooms nice beautiful Cambridge
hereare Hotel rent to rent I'm paying
100 Grand a year that's bringing me in a
profit I mean I've only had it a few
months but my projections on that are
it's going to bring me in about 150
Grand profit after all expenses a year
on a rent to rent and the great thing is
I also have the option to buy after 10
years but that's another story you know
rent to rent on a big scale you can
easily have uh not just a million pound
company but if you've got a few of them
over a couple few years you got you got
a million pounds quite straightforward
of rent to rent third way that you can
become a millionaire is through basic
buy toir I know bu toet is a bit boring
because the reason it's boring is
because the cash flow is boring because
on average for a buy toet let's say you
buy a house for 200 Grand and you rent
it out for £1,500 well your mortgage
costs are probably going to be around
about6 700 and then you've got a
management company managing it and then
you've got your maintenance you might be
left with £300 a month profit rubbish
you know so bu that's boring but here's
the thing think when you've got a bunch
of byet properties let's say you've got
10 and they're each paying you £300 a
month and you're making three grand a
month passive income from your B toets
it's not amazing you're a broker you're
making three grand a month from your bu
toets not life changing but and this is
what happened to me if you buy a
property for 200 Grand and you put down
say a 25% deposit at 50 Grand right so
you put down 50 Grand and you buy 200
grand house housies go up in value over
time after a 10 year on average every 10
years property's double in value if you
got 10 of those and they're all 200
Grand and they double in value now
you've got 400 Grand per property that's
£4 million now sure you've got mortgages
but your mortgages are only small how
much would you be left with so each
property if you put down 50 grand for a
200 grand house if they double that
means you now got a 400 grand house
minus your mortgage of 150 so each
property has got Equity of 250 quarter
of a million pound Equity yours your net
times up by 10 if you got 10 boletes and
they double that's 2.5 million you know
how many people become millionaires by
mistake just by owning properties if you
own properties and sit on them even if
they're only making a little bit of
money each month over time you could be
very easily become an accidental
millionaire how many millions of pounds
I've made by mistake just by owning real
estate number four is property
development making a million pounds in
property development is not even a big
deal most developers won't even touch an
opportunity unless they're going to make
7 figer profits which is at least a
million P My First Property development
publicly documented in Lincoln where we
built houses from scratch bought the
land for 330 Grand spent half a million
pound building six houses that's 830 but
then the end value was 1.4 million
that's half a million in 9 months from
developing from building now some of the
developments that we're looking at we
bought a factory last year for a million
and we're turning it into Flats we got
planning permission turn into 48 flats
and the the end value is £ 6.7 million
there's many millions of pounds worth of
profit in the deal it's a banger so
property development is a way where you
can make a million pounds per
development deal but a lot of property
developers are very very rich because
instead of waiting for capital
appreciation or getting little drips of
rent you're pushing the value up and
getting chunks of change and then you
can either sell or refinance that's not
story you've still made millions of
pounds to your net worth next number
five if you're enjoying the video by the
way hit like everything I'm telling you
I've done I'm not saying here's how you
can make a million pounds theoretically
every single one of these I've done
number five is planning permission so
for example in 2020 a few years ago when
we went to lockdown I was Finding pieces
of land that didn't have planning
permission just grass and was buying
them on an option so I was saying to the
owner how much do you want for the land
and the owner's not got planning
permission it's just a piece of grass oh
I have 100 Grand per perfect I'll give
you 100 Grand in 12 months time subject
to planning permission and then he might
oh well I'm not sure maybe I'll try and
get planning myself or okay well you've
owned the land 14 years go for it oh I
haven't got the connections I haven't
got the all right how about this I'll
give you 10 grand now and then in 12
months I'll give you 90 grand to buy the
land if in 12 months I don't give you
the 90 grand you keep the 10 right
things like that in fact that should be
Point number number five should be how
to make negotiations like I've made many
many many millions in negotiations so
that's 0. five but 6 now is planning
permission in the real estate game the
profit is in the planning you know how
many times I've secured a piece of land
and I've got planning to build two or
three houses and I've not bothered to
even build them I've got the planning on
the land then I've got the option to buy
it for 100 grand but now the land's
worth 300 Grand okay so why am I going
to bother building I haven't lifted a
shovel at this point I've got the option
to buy for 100 and now I can just find a
new buyer and pass it to them for 300
and pocket change to 200 Grand I SP £1.6
million doing this exact strategy across
six sites during lockdown when everyone
was lock down and everyone was you know
waiting to go back to work I was doing
this walking around it's about what you
could do in lockdown walk walking around
Buckingham share the Midlands finding
bits of land approaching the seller
negotiating and then profiting from the
planning using option agreements and and
point seven is basic residential
purchase lease option agreements even
now to this day I just bought a property
a few weeks ago and it was about4 5%
below market value below not below
market value from a year ago cuz houses
have gone down below current true market
value and it was like how did you do
that cuz I agreed the price 7 years ago
you I made deals even when I was like a
teenager like 19 I secured oh right you
want to sell your house you want 200
grand for it listen I'll give you 200
Grand but in seven years but right now
I'll take over the property I'll take
over the mortgage payments and you might
think well who on Earth would sell their
house like that who would let you buy
their house in seven years and agree the
price today for instance people in
negative equity and guess what there's
loads of those right now if you want to
do more and you want to start doing
deals like this I'm running a property
investor crash course where I'm going to
be spending a full day finding these
types of deals right at the property
crash because I'm going to be finding
development deals finding land
opportunities commercial to gez there's
loads more as well commercial to
residential I didn't even touch on that
there's so many ways that you can make
millions of pounds and it might not be
quick right I'm not saying for a minute
that you're going to be able to come to
my1 crash course cuz that's how much my
course is1
right I lose money doing doing those
training programs I'm not saying you're
going to find a deal and make a million
pounds no what you'll do is you'll learn
to find deals you might start by finding
these deals and just passing them to
investors and charging a fee that would
be a good way to start and then you
might start on a little small deal a
little small lease option you might
start with a buy to let sit on it and
wait I'm not saying it's going to be
fast it's not fast it's not easy but I
tell you what it is damn worthwhile and
if you're going to work hard anyway you
may as well get rich so I'd love to
spend the day with you I'll leave a link
in the description where you can come
down spend one day with me for1
spaces are limited so get booked on now
and uh I look forward to meeting you in
person let's go